[Música]
en el mundo laboral se nos mide
principalmente por nuestro conocimiento
a nivel de experiencia y práctica en lo
que hacemos pero hay otras habilidades
personales que son esenciales para el
óptimo desarrollo en el trabajo estas
son las llamadas habilidades blandas y
que son pues se lo preguntamos a
virginia gallardo el socio consultor de
human nova experto en gestión del cambio
y recursos humanos gracias virginio por
estar con nosotros esta mañana de
viernes aquí en directo américa de
france 24 explicamos un un poco más
entonces qué son estas llamadas
habilidades blandas
se denominan competencias
tradicionalmente hace unos 25 o 30 años
que los psicólogos laborales
establecieron que las personas que
tienen un mayor rendimiento en el
trabajo poseían estas características
que se han denominado muchas formas
esquel
habilidades blandas
o competencias son digamos habilidades
transversales que son comunes en muchos
fajos como colaboración
algunas relacionadas con inteligencia
emocional como empatía como como
influencia como proactividad
características que digamos no dependen
tanto no son tan cognitivas no dependen
del conocimiento y depende más de
vamos a decirlo así de como de unas
actitudes y nuevos comportamientos que
finalmente se reflejan pero que no son
tan fáciles digámoslo así de aprender
claro que serían las habilidades duras
cuál es la importancia de tenerlas
digamos en el ambiente laboral para
nuestro para nuestro desarrollo y el
sano ambiente digamos de convivencia con
nuestros compañeros de trabajo
las competencias estas competencias
blandas o competencias son lo que
diferencia a un profesional bueno de un
profesional normal o mediocre
es decir una vez que ya tienes los
conocimientos
una vez que eres vamos a decirlo así
estudia este periodismo ya es tu
capacidad de influencia tu capacidad de
comunicación tu capacidad de
identificarte con el otro lo que hace
que tengan su mejor rendimiento por
tanto
las empresas las quieren los
profesionales las quieren les quieren
desarrollar porque es lo que hace que
tengas mejor rendimiento me preguntabas
por el entorno afectan en nuestro
entorno y hay muchas que sí afectan de
una forma radical tú sobre todo las
habilidades emocionales las de las
denominadas
habilidades relacionadas con la relación
personal o interpersonales por ejemplo
hasta qué punto escuchas a los demás
hasta qué punto que no se encuentra sus
puntos de vista hasta qué punto tienen
se encuentra sus emociones hasta qué
punto de vista en líderes bien si eres
un jefe porque son más importantes los
responsables jerárquicos todo hasta todo
este tipo de cosas hace que creemos
ambientes y entornos laborales mejores
que no nos engañemos también también
impacta muchísimo en el rendimiento por
tanto no solamente sirven para obtener
digamos más resultados sino para crear
entornos que a su vez crean más
resultados
claro virginio le quiero preguntar si
todos tenemos de alguna manera estas
habilidades o si la podemos desarrollar
no que tan innata son o que objetan
adquiridas pueden ser
las competencias es cierto que no es
como vamos a ver no es como aprender a
hacer
una derivada no se trata de 20
pasos y las tienes pero sí que es cierto
que se pueden desarrollar
su desarrollo es más complejo
vamos a ver algunas competencias veremos
como el desarrollo es más complejo todos
somos hepáticos no sé que tengas algún
tipo de enfermedad tipo de asperger
quizá no sea muy empático pero en
general toda la población es empática
ahora
podemos hacer y ser más eficientes en
una escucha activa si se puede aprender
se puede aprender esto nos dará grandes
ventajas nos dará muchísimas ventajas
es decir si somos capaces de reconocer a
los demás si somos capaces de hacerles
un digamos una comunicación más
agradable esto nos ayudará a que nos
que mejora la comunicación y por tanto a
tener mejor relación con los demás y
esto influirá en nuestro trabajo por
supuesto todo todos estos pasos se
podrían llegar a aprender se pueden
llegar a aprender hay personas que sin
haber estudiado nunca nada son más
empáticas y otras personas que sin
habiendo hecho los esfuerzos son menos
empáticas eso no quiere decir que
podamos lograr más camps a ti a nuestra
colaboración nuestra productividad
nuestra iniciativa nuestra creatividad
etcétera se puede uno volver más
creativo cumbre pues si te podrías
volver más creativo no es tan fácil
digámoslo así como aprender a programar
por ejemplo que sabes que si haces
mentiras pues acabará sabiendo cómo
funciona tabla excel no es tan
automático pero si en el sentimiento se
puede desarrollar
y además de es casi obligatorio
desarrollarlas por ejemplo en europa
especialmente en españa últimamente
en otros países como los escandinavos
hace ya unos 5 ó 10 años a los niños se
les enseña determinadas competencias y
la vila con la formación se orienta a
conveniencias cosas que también está
llegando a latinoamérica en algunos con
escribió se ha de hacer es un discurso
que de alguna forma ya está calando la
comunidad creativa por tanto se pueden
desarrollar claro virginio también
hablabas de un reconocimiento le quiero
preguntar qué tan fácil o qué tan
difícil son identificar estas llamadas
habilidades blandas a la hora de una
contratación como una empresa puede
identificar que puede tener un potencial
potencial el líder para el ingreso a la
compañía
pues mira esa es la pregunta clave
cuando por ejemplo selecciona son
directivos pero también es la pregunta
clave cuando selecciones a un vendedor o
es la pregunta clave cuando seleccionas
a alguien de atención al cliente o es la
pregunta clave cuando coges a un
coordinador por ejemplo este tipo de
puestos que son muy exigentes en
habilidades blandas por ejemplo dobladas
la de un directivo un directivo sin
liderazgo digamos que no es un directivo
no son libres es un jefe y creará un
clima pésimo y por muy buen profesional
que sea probablemente sus colaboradores
a sus colaboradores no no cree el clima
y les va a ganar el rendimiento de estos
salva por tanto efectivamente cuando
seleccionamos los profesionales tanto
cuando promocionamos como cuando
seleccionamos este realmente los
profesores tienen que tener muy en
cuenta estas habilidades blandas incluso
te diría más que las habilidades duras
es decir se tú tiene estos profesionales
uno que es bueno y otro que es muy bueno
en habilidades duras por ejemplo vamos a
imaginarnos en programación pero los
tienes que subir al jefe quizá lo que
más te interese no entre ellos dos ya es
quién es mejor líder y por supuesto
habría que a que tuviera mejor
liderazgo porque las competencias donde
se pueden es más fácil desarrollar las
competencias blandas tardarás más y no
siempre es tan fácil desarrollarlas por
tanto es muy
importante en algunos puestos como el
que tú hablabas seleccionar las escalas
la clave del éxito es fundamental